a new type of health test uses your DNA
to give nutritional advice people are
spending hundreds of dollars to map out
the genetic profile with a saliva test
there are several tests on the market
but critics say it is hard to know how
accurate they are Michelle Miller sat
down with one woman who says a DNA test
helped in years of stomach pain I cut
out carbs I wasn't eating dairy every
time Rebecca Cassell sat down to eat her
favorite foods
she says she suffered excruciating
abdominal pain pain unable to stand
unable to stand yeah it's terrible
terrible like sharp shooting pain
bloating distention that pain went on
for more than two years Cassell saw
multiple doctors then she took a DNA
metabolic test I was allergic to starch
that's mostly root vegetables corn peas
sweet potatoes so this is what you spit
in Nikki shook is a performance
nutritionist what's the typical client
who's interested in these DNA tests one
is the athlete that's looking to improve
performance in their athletic event and
then folks like Rebecca they know their
body and they know something is off even
though it's a genetic test it's
effectively dietary advice and
counseling an individual on how to eat
better
I met Elsa he me is the chief science
officer at nutrigenomics individual
genetic differences can help us
understand why some people respond
differently from others nutrigenomics
says their DNA test looks at a person's
forty-five genetic markers they make a
recommendation based on the patient's
genetic profile pointing out attributes
like an elevated risk for low iron we're
talking about metabolic tests their
genetic tests but they affect the way
that you metabolize various substances
that you consume
DNA tests for diet and exercise just are
not validated dr. David agus is the CBS
News contributor so are any of these
tests accurate they're very few of them
that actually have data behind them and
to me that's a problem you know you had
companies like 23andme that were taken
off the market for several years because
they had to show data with regard to
human disease
well I think the same thing needs to
happen with nutrition and exercise the
FDA says they support tests that may
provide consumers with direct genetic
information that can inform health
related decisions but the agency points
out it does not actively regulate these
products 2,400 years ago Hippocrates did
something amazing is that he would eat
something and he would write down how he
felt after he ate it to me that's the
best way in the world to know what's
right for you it goes through your iron
status whole grain sodium Castle says
the tests produced more than 30 pages of
results about her body which means she
can now avoid the foods that set off her
stomach I think it's worth it you don't
need your blood taken you're literally
just spitting into a test tube you could
do it in your sleep for CBS this morning
Michelle Miller
everyone wants a prescription on hand to
their goal but looking for a magic
bullet
exactly but I'll take that magic bullet
anytime if I have one your pilot eager
buy it